if you're hoping that you'll be able to
play halo 5 on your PC then get ready
for disappointment I'm Lucy aunt welcome
to your console exclusive gamespot news
update Xbox boss Phil Spencer has
discussed with a halo 5 is likely to
make the jump from xbox one to PC just
like four to six killer instinct and
quantum break have done as reported by
PC gamer speaking during Microsoft's
build 2016 conference Spencer indicated
that halo 5 specifically wasn't likely
to be released for the pc but left the
door open for future titles he said in
terms of halo a first-person shooter on
PC I think there's a ton of opportunity
for us right now but I don't want to get
into a world where we're looking back
like at halo five that doesn't mean
there's nothing there that could ever
end up on pc but I'd much rather look
forward with what our plans are
elsewhere during the Q&A session Spencer
outline Microsoft strategy in bringing
xbox one games to PC and vice versa he
noted that a game suitability for each
platform was a major factor not just
whether it supports controller or mouse
and keyboard you should expect releases
on both xbox one and pc but I wouldn't
go so far as to say it's a mandate for
the studio's because it's not Microsoft
previously confirmed that four to six
apex a free-to-play version of four to
six was just the first entry in the
racing series to come to PC turn turn
creative director Dan Greenawalt
revealed the company plans to release
all future for two games for both xbox
and pc so what are your feelings on PC
and Xbox sharing games what do you make
of xboxes PC strategy let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm Malusi James games more on
xbox and pc keeper gamespot